[موسيقى]
مستمره التي سنتين
في نهايتها
[موسيقى]
هي نتيجه لمحادثات استمرت لسنتين وصلنا في
نهايتها الى تفاهمات مبنيه على حسن الجوار
واحترام وسياده الدول ومعالجه كافه تحديات
الامن الاقليمي من خلال هذا الحوار وقناعه
المملكه العربيه السعوديه ان الحوار هو
الاسلوب الانجع الى معالجه كافه
[موسيقى]
بتفاعل الى المستقبل ونعمل على توطيد
العلاقه وخدمه المصالح جميع دول المنطقه
وحمايه امن المنطقه وهذا مرض واحده ان شاء
الله
[موسيقى]
اللبنان يحتاج ان يعمل تقارب لبناني ليس
لبناني ايراني سعودي وفي النهايه والبدايه
على لبنان ان ينظر لمصلحته وعلى الشاشه
وهذا اقولها دائما ان يقدم المصلحه
اللبنانيه على اي مصلحه متى ما حدث هذا
ومثل ما اتخذ قرارا في لبنان بتقديم
المصلحه اللبنانيه والعمل على
بناء الدوله اللبنانيه فسوف يزدهر
بالتاكيد
[موسيقى]
الوضع القائم غير قابل للاستدامه ولا بد
ان نجد سبيلنا لتحطي التحديات الذي يفرضها
هذا الوضع القائم فيما يتعلق باللاجئين
بوضع الانساني داخل سوريا ولذلك لابد ان
نجد مقاربه جديده وهذا سيتطلب لا محاله
حوار مع الحكومه في دمشق ونحن والدول
العربيه نعمل على الصياغات المناسبه
بالتشاور ايضا مع شركائنا في المجتمع
[موسيقى]
وهذا
تطورات الاخيره
للغايه انا اخشى اننا نقبل على دوره من
التصعيد لن نستطيع ايقافها وهنا تقع
المسؤوليه على جانب اسرائيلي لوقت هذا
الاجراءات المتتاليه في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه والعمل على تحيه الاجواء
المناسبه للعوده للحوار ونحن جائز عازمون
على الدفع في مسار الحوار لحل هذه القضيه
التي طالت